what's wrong with Congress the premise
of our constitution by having separate
branches and having the ability to check
each other was that ambition would
counteract the ambition you're the
executive by human nature you want to
expand your power I'm in the Congress
it's human nature we want our our Branch
to be the most powerful so you'd be
fighting back and forth what's happened
with the modern Congress is their desire
to remain in office has inverted that so
they would rather draft vague
legislation that punts the critical
decisions to the bureaucracy so that
they have plausible deniability in a
re-election campaign when there's no
constitutional accountability you're
going to have power
accumulate and it's going to be wielded
in ways that are going to be detrimental
that's that's basically 101 from what
our Founders thought so they need to get
serious about exercising their Authority
and I think the Decades of them
defaulting on that responsibility have
led to where we are now